well guys the summer is officially over
September is here and movie season sucks
for a while so I decided let's talk
about some things that you guys have
been asking me to talk about for a long
time
these are my picks for the top 10 best
comic book films of all time as of 2014
September because next year some stuff
might go down I don't know what's gonna
happen and what better shirt to wear
than this I mean look at this thing the
shirt is absurdly amazing it's I I want
to touch it
no I good buddy on YouTube the flick pic
or John Flickinger recently published
his top 10 worst comic book movies of
all time and you know what he told me he
said if I didn't mention him at the
beginning of this video he was gonna put
me in a headlock and punch me like the
dweeb that I am but seriously I'm not
gonna do a top 10 worst for a while in
regards to comic book film so if you
guys want to know some cool opinions
about that go check out his video on his
channel because they're very similar to
mine in regards to what I would pick as
well but enough chitchat let's get
started with number 10
Superman the movie came out in 1978 and
it launched the modern superhero genre
for a while it was just Superman movies
and they didn't really know what to do
it wasn't until 1989 when they decided
to go forth with Batman and Tim Burton
did a pretty good job with that as well
but Superman the movie was one of the
first times that superheroes were ever
taken seriously on film Christopher
Reeve to this day is Superman I mean the
guy just owned the role and he was
fantastic as Clark Kent is well my dad
told me about the first time he saw this
movie in theaters and he said that
everyone was just in awe not just at the
special effects but the fact that they
were actually not laughing because up
until that time superhero films were
more comedy oriented the first
appearance from a film that came out
this year on this list is x-men Days of
Future past I'm a huge x-men fan I've
loved almost all of the x-men movies
some of them aren't too good x-men 3
x-men origins but x-men Days of Future
past was Bryan Singer's triumphant
return to the franchise in which he was
able to take the characters from x-men
first class and from his original x-men
series combine them and make something
way more epic than most people were
expecting
my pick for number eight is a relatively
unknown film that I think needs to be
way more known that it is and that is
Batman mask of the phantasm
I appreciated the first two Batman films
I like Batman I like Batman Returns but
Batman mask of the phantasm was my
favorite Batman movie for quite some
time it was based off the original
animated series which I also loved from
the early 90s and it was a deep dark
gritty animated tale that explored
Batman's roots like none of the feature
films prior had my pick for number 7 is
a comeback role for the one and only
Robert Downey jr. he was already pretty
famous in the 90s went through a lot of
problems and then all of a sudden he was
just there was nothing I mean he was
gone he was who would have thought that
this guy after going through everything
he went through which is good play the
perfect Iron Man Tony Stark combination
he did such a fantastic job in this role
that I honestly could not picture
another person playing that role and he
is still playing that role to this day
because no one else wants him to change
Jon Favreau did a fantastic job
directing that movie the action
sequences looked amazing the story was
good the characterizations were awesome
everything about Iron Man worked there's
been a lot of Spider Man movies so far
the last two huh hmm yeah
Spider Man when I grew up was actually
my favorite superhero I loved everything
spider-man and that is why spider-man 2
to this day is still my favorite
spider-man film this film understood the
character of spider-man so well and it
also was able to tell a really good
dramatic story while maintaining the fun
and cheesy origins of spider-man's
comics because if you go back and read
some of the spider-man comics from the
60s which is what Sam Raimi was trying
to tribute a lot with his original films
you're gonna see a lot of corn you're
gonna see a lot of cheese and they
understood that with these films but
they were also able to make them more
gritty that train sequence has anyone
complained about that train sequence you
can complain about Tobey Maguire's poop
face but it's still amazing I love that
train sequence it's one of my favourite
action scenes in a superhero film to
this day and it still holds up ten years
later my Gunners his films ten years old
my pick for number five is yet another
film from this year Captain America the
Winter Soldier another example of a
sequel that was better than the first
one that understood what the character
was but made it a lot better than what
they already tried to do see the best
part about a superhero sequel is that
now you've got the origin story out of
the way you don't have to deal with all
that stuff anymore now you can just show
this guy in his prime doing what he does
best and Captain America the Winter
Soldier understood that immensely this
was a fantastic spy action thriller it
had amazing action sequences done by two
directors who are primarily known for
comedy Chris Evans owned as Captain
America in this movie if there was ever
any doubt about him playing that
character I'm pretty sure they pretty
much eliminated that already but if
there was ever that one guy who was like
I need a badass Captain America where is
he this film gave us that guardians of
the galaxy how can you not like this
movie it understood its characters so
well it had an amazing soundtrack
fantastic special effects well directed
action it was very hilarious
well-written it was a really hard movie
to get right to because it's not a
Captain America movie it's not a
spider-man movie Hulk doesn't show up at
any time during this movie nor does Iron
Man so you have a whole bunch of
characters that no one really knew that
much about except for the hardcore fans
of the source material and yet it has
become not only the highest-grossing
comic book film of the year it has
become the highest-grossing film of the
year as of right now Marvel spent so
many years leading up to the Avengers
and it paid off big-time because they
got a director and a writer like Joss
Whedon who understands not only how to
tell a very cool story and make it fun
and interesting to watch but he had
great dialogue for these characters that
he also understood very well and that
dialogue was so important because the
first time we get to see these
characters sitting in a room together
doing stuff and fighting bad guys
together so yes that's cool to see but
what are they gonna talk about Joss
Whedon understood that getting that
dialogue right between the characters
getting it fun witty adventurous and
interesting and smart getting that right
was one of the reasons the Avengers
worked so well
and of course you can see Hulk smash a
whole bunch of stuff
at number two I'm going to break the
rules a little bit because this is a
film that is not based off of any comic
book that's out there this is a film
that is all about comic books though and
features a central protagonist that has
yet to discover he's a superhero
unbreakable is one of my all-time
favorite movies I find it very
underrated I think that it is M night
Shyamalan second best film my favorite
of his being signs Willis's character
has never been harmed in his life he
survives a horrific train accident and
samuel l.jackson is convinced this guy's
a superhero and he spends the entire
film trying to convince him that he is
one unbreakable I think is one of the
best superhero movies that no one ever
calls a superhero movie if you haven't
seen unbreakable check it out because I
really think it's worth your time my
number one pick is a little bit
complicated I didn't want to have these
movies all spread throughout this list
at various parts so I'm gonna cheat
again and say that my number one pick
for the best comic book film ever made
is the Dark Knight trilogy Christopher
Nolan's trilogy for Batman is in my
opinion the best incarnation of a
superhero we have ever seen on screen
with that first film Batman Begins he
just nailed the origin story finally in
live-action Batman mask of the phantasm
had a fantastic hoard in a story in
animation but never had we seen it in
live-action because Tim Burton's
original film well good
he was Batman from the beginning we
never got to see that training and
training him with Ra's al Ghul and all
that stuff with his parents made for
such a big emotional payoff as you
progress with Batman throughout this
movie do I even need to express why the
Dark Knight is a good movie not only is
he fled Jers portrayal of the Joker
iconic at this point scary and real and
also darkly funny but the entire film as
an action thriller was lifted far above
its predecessor and I for one love The
Dark Knight Rises it was great to see a
villain Bane played by Tom Hardy who is
physically superior to Batman because up
until then no one actually challenged
Batman physically to see Batman in fear
was something that we hadn't seen before
and that really added to the dramatic
depth of this movie and of course the
last hour of this film is some of the
most breathtaking filmmaking I've seen
ever so guys those are my picks for the
top 10 best comic book films of all time
I hope
you guys enjoy this list thank you so
much for watching I had a lot of fun
talking about these things comic book
movies are kind of important to me I
grew up on them they're nostalgic for me
and when they're treated with respect
there's something in me that just goes
thank you thank you you understand also
recently I shared an image on my Twitter
about something that I've recently
acquired and a lot of people were like
salivating over it relay dude where'd
you get that I need to know where you
got that right now because I need my
hands on that I got this incredible
Breaking Bad wood carving and I'm in
love with it I touch it a lot I got this
from space wolf limited calm these guys
are incredibly awesome in fact these
guys contacted me and wanted to sponsor
some of my videos and I was like you've
got to be kidding me you guys do some of
the coolest stuff on the Internet
these guys are independent artists there
are only 50 of all of their designs that
are made and then they are gone for ever
they plant a tree for each item sold how
incredible is that and through me you
can use the coupon code stuckman yes my
last name I'm going to cry and you get
25% off your order so that is so awesome
definitely go to space wolf limited calm
these guys are super nice they have
amazing products and let them know that
I sent you and use the coupon code
stuckman guys thank you so much as
always for watching this video I look
forward to doing more top 10s maybe
something for Halloween
we'll see as always guys thank you so
much and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck Minh iced